das müssen sie heute wissen über diesen
ukraine krieg moskau bereitet offenbar
die bombardierung von odessa vor also
dieser großstadt am schwarzen meer das
hat der ukrainische präsident selensky
eben gesagt zudem hat die evakuierung in
mario pohl wohl begonnen wir hören von
300 menschen die dort raus gebracht
worden werden konnten das sind nicht
allzu viele es gab auch meldung dass das
nicht funktioniert hat weil die
waffenruhe eben wieder nicht
funktioniert hat dort im mario pohl weil
die wieder nicht gehalten hat dazu
liefern wir ihnen gleich nähere
informationen außerdem gab es ein
wichtiges telefonat heute noch mal vom
israelischen
premier naftali bennett mit selensky
bennett das wissen sie er könnte dort zu
einem art zu einer art ganz wichtiger
figur in den verhandlungen zwischen
ukrainischer und russischer seite werden
und ja in russland funktionieren visa
card und mastercard mittlerweile nicht
mehr visa und mastercard haben komplett
im betrieb dort in russland eingestellt
und wir zeigen ihnen diese bilder von
einem verlassenen russischen konvoi
nordöstlich von charkiw im winterlichen
in der winterlichen ukraine dort völlig
aufgegeben dieser konvoi die spuren des
krieges hier im schnee ukrainische
soldaten die darüber triumphieren also
auch das sind bilder dieses krieges
schwere russische
verluste offenbar in diesen tagen in
diesen stunden gleichzeitig sind die
kämpfe aber auch in charkiw
beispielsweise im osten des landes
heftig es gibt bilder eine auto kamera
dieser des cam ihr handy kamera die
einen schweren raketeneinschlag gefilmt
hat ihr direkt vor dem auto explodiert
eine rakete das ist der kriegsalltag
derzeit dort im osten des landes tag 11
in putins blutigen krieg und seine armee
die wird offenbar immer ehren loser die
soldaten schießen jetzt sogar gezielt
auf unbewaffnete demonstranten in der
ukrainischen siedlung nowaks kopf das
ist in der nähe von lohans gas in der
ost ukraine
da sind menschen ganz friedlich ohne
waffen das sehen sie alte menschen
frauen auf die straße gegangen wollten
dort gegen die besatzer gegen die
russische armee einfach demonstrieren
und es gab schüsse auf diese menschen
auf zivilisten mindestens ein mann ist
dabei schwer verletzt worden